ah ah ah ça serait drôle j'adorais qu'on
l'entende of banalement on est en soirée
il ya des mojitos il ya du il ya du son
il ya des dj derrière c'est et sinon
charlène bonne année coeur ou yann
barthès ils sont sympas dans la vraie
vie
alors bon celle ci elle est un peu
fatigante parce qu'il revient
régulièrement
et puis et puis je me pose la question
aussi de pourquoi on me la posent
régulièrement cette question là et je
pense parce que en fait les gens doivent
se dire inconsciemment que même si les
gens ont l'air sympathique à la télé ou
à la radio
dans la vraie vie ils sont forcément l'
inverse c'est à dire qu'il y aurait un
côté artificiel et et faux dans la télé
ce qui peut être le cas mais pas pour
pas pour nos amis belges charline van
den acker alex vizorek et autres où il
ya de barthez qui sont pour le coup
vraiment sympathique dans dans la vraie
vie mais c'est ce côté là de remettre en
cause quelque chose qui pourtant les
vrais qui me fatigue un peu
pablo mira est ce que c'est ton vrai nom
j'ai du mal à comprendre la question
parce que oui ok il ya un côté
hispanisants quai paquet pas ordinaire
qui est pas dans la norme mais genre si
je devais choisir un nom de scène je
m'appellerai pas comme ça en fait
j'aurais choisi autre chose j'aurais
choisi will smith par exemple je me
serais appelé will smith on aurait été
deux ça aurait été dur de m'imposer par
rapport à l'autre mais pablo mira c'est
pas non plus un super super nom de scène
ou alors lille quelque chose tu vois
lille pablo à la rigueur là il peut se
passer quelque chose mais d'un point de
vue marketing pablo mira ça n'a aucun
intérêt au fait est ce que pour vous
l'humour doit dénoncer
ça on est sûr techniquement la question
de l'enfer puisque au fait je considère
que moisson il doit pas faire quelque
chose ou pas faire quelque chose le seul
but de l'humour ça reste de faire rire
les gens que tu essayes de faire
hérisser de l'enfermer dans une espèce
de deux missions sociales ou politiques
je trouve que c'est lui c'est vraiment
le limiter ces essais de l'enfermer dans
quelque chose qui est plus petit que ce
qu'il est vraiment notre question qui
revient souvent et qui me fatigue qui me
prend en énergie généralement je suis en
crise d'hypoglycémie après qu'on me les
poser c'est deux points ouvrez les
guillemets vous êtes combien aux
graffitis ou avec sa variante mais sinon
vous êtes combien logo raffy je trouve
que c'est dommage de répondre à cette
question là parce que ça enlève un peu
de magie et de mystère au graphie à on a
essayé d'être un peu les au début les
daft punk de la blague sur internet
on n'est pas allé jusqu au même degré de
notoriété on n'a pas remporté de prix de
victoires de la musique de choses comme
ça
mais voilà je trouve que c'est ce qui
est intéressant avec logo raffy c'est
con on voit pas trop chi chi le qui le
fait qu'ils composent la rédaction est
ce que ce sont des vraies personnes des
algorithmes chinois on sait pas
j'aimerais garder ce mystère si possible
l'autre question qui me qui me fait
hérisser les poils il y en a quand même
une petite quantité
c est ce que vous vous interdisez des
choses des sujets des thèmes et tout ça
alors compliqué il faudrait trois heures
mais en vrai oui il ya des choses qu'il
ya des sujets qui m'intéressent pas
naturellement outre où je les trouve pas
dignes d'intérêt et puis il ya des il ya
des types de vannes qui trouve aussi on
pas d'intérêt comique par exemple faire
des vannes sur je dis n'importe quoi par
l'ondé les victimes d'un désastre
tremblement terre un crash d'avion je
trouve pas que ça ait un super super
intérêts comique alors d'autres trouvent
que sans ça en a pas moi et je trouve
que c'est ça rapporte pas grand chose en
termes de propos donc je les mets de
côté